Transcriptor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Hace algún tiempo vi una película
dirigida por Ethan Hawks
llamada "Seymour: Una introducción".
Y recuerdo perfectamente
unos pocos segundos de la película
cuando el personaje principal
de la historia,
el pianista, compositor y maestro
Seymour Bernstein, dijo:
"Lo más importante es inspirar
una respuesta emocional
en todos los aspectos de la vida".
Él le estaba diciendo esto
a sus alumnos de piano
y, de inmediato, descubrí que
esto era absolutamente cierto.
No solo al enseñar sino, como decía,
en todos los aspectos de la vida.
De hecho, hay innumerables
trabajos de investigación
y experiencias prácticas
que demuestran que los estudiantes
mejoran su aprendizaje
cuando están involucrados
emocionalmente en el proceso.
Les cuento esto porque
la historia que les relataré
me emociona mucho, y realmente
espero que también lo haga con Uds.
Desde hace 38 años que soy profesor
aquí, en esta facultad,
y esta es una historia
de enseñanza y aprendizaje.
Pero es una historia
en la que no soy yo el que enseña,
sino el que aprendió.
Aprendí una de las lecciones
más importantes de toda mi vida.
Y el que me la enseñó fue mi hijo.
Así que permítanme comenzar esta
historia diciéndoles que tengo 59 años,
que he estado casado
con mi querida esposa Susy
desde hace más de 30 años,
y que tenemos dos maravillosos hijos:
Jésica de 28 años
y Damián de 25.
Nací en una familia judía de clase media
en la que viví una vida
relativamente normal,
en la que ciertas cosas se establecieron
como reglas de facto.
Se suponía que debía casarme
con una mujer judía
y tener una familia judía,
con hijos que, eventualmente,
continuarían esa tradición.
En ese escenario supuestamente ideal,
no había lugar para dudas
o conceptos erróneos.
Un hombre debía casarse con una mujer
y una mujer debía casarse con un hombre.
Sin dudas, sin conflictos.
Cualquier otra posibilidad debería
ser eliminada de nuestras vidas.
Porque era simplemente impensable,
imposible de aceptar.
Además, esto era algo que nosotros
nunca habíamos discutido
en nuestra familia, ¿para qué?
En nuestro mundo ideal
este tipo de cosas no existen.
Pero esto era cierto no solo para
mi familia, sino también en la escuela,
donde cualquier tipo de señal de ternura
en un niño sería castigada.
No solo por sus compañeros
sino también por los maestros.
Y la misma situación
en los programas de televisión,
en los deportes y dondequiera que vayan.
Un hombre debe ser un macho.
Y cualquier signo de debilidad o flojedad
merecería recibir
el apelativo de maricón.
Díganme la verdad, ¿no les suena esto?
Especialmente, si no son muy jóvenes.
Por lo tanto, era normal para mí creer
que esta era la única verdad
y que todas las otras posibilidades
estaban equivocadas.
Un error.
Por desgracia,
hemos vivido durante siglos
en un mundo de falsas certezas.
En un mundo regido por normas
religiosas graves e inmutables.
Permítanme citar
algunos párrafos de la Biblia.
"Cuando el Señor terminó de hablarle
a Moisés en el monte Sinaí
le dio las dos tablas
de la ley del pacto.
Las tablas de piedra gravadas
con el dedo de Dios".
La ley fue escrita en piedra
por el dedo de Dios.
¿Cómo atrevernos a modificarla,
a ir en contra de lo que
se estableció previamente?
Y este es otro párrafo bíblico:
"Si alguien se acuesta con otro hombre
como se hace con una mujer,
abominación hicieron;
ambos han de ser muertos:
sobre ellos caerá su sangre".
Puedo continuar con otros ejemplos,
pero creo que alcanza
para entender a qué me refiero.
Nuestros padres, sus padres,
y todos nuestros antepasados,
fueron educados bajo estas leyes
y nosotros recibimos esta educación.
Y no había posibilidad de pensar
de una manera diferente.
Y si alguien se atrevía
a sentirse diferente
mejor que oculte sus sentimientos
para no ser visto como un extraño.
Como alguien que está fuera
de este mundo "perfecto".
Por lo tanto, si nos equivocamos,
no fue culpa de nuestros padres
ni de nuestros abuelos,
fue culpa de la herencia humana.
Pero no digo esto
como una especie de excusa.
Realmente, creo que somos absoluta
y únicamente responsables
de nuestros propios actos.
Pero déjenme continuar con mi historia.
Durante mis primeros
45 años, más o menos,
viví bajo esas falsas certezas.
Y nunca imaginé
cuán dañino pudo haber sido
expresar algunas bromas o comentarios
sin ninguna mala intención.
Pero luego sucedió que mi hijo,
mi propio y amado hijo,
habló conmigo sobre sus sentimientos,
que le gustan los hombres, que es gay.
En ese momento me enfrenté
con todas mis creencias anteriores,
con toda mi historia personal de vida.
Era mi hijo el que me decía esto.
Y yo lo amo.
Y quiero que él tenga
la vida más feliz posible.
Y toda mi vida cambió en ese momento.
Por supuesto, yo lo apoyé.
Le di un abrazo y le dije que su felicidad
era lo más importante para mí.
Pero al mismo tiempo descubrí
lo fuerte que debió haber sido él
para transitar todos estos años
desde que descubrió
sus verdaderos sentimientos,
hasta que finalmente pudo ser
quien realmente es.
Qué tan fuerte debió haber sido él
para no enfrentar a aquellos
que, como yo,
se referían sin querer de manera grosera
acerca de personas homosexuales.
Qué triste y culpable
me sentí en ese momento
por los comentarios anteriores
que podría haber dicho
sin mala intención,
pero con mucha ignorancia.
Y fue en ese momento cuando me di cuenta
de que mi hijo me estaba
enseñando una lección.
Una de las más importantes
de toda mi vida.
Y esa lección fue que
no tenemos derecho a hacer
que alguien más sienta pena por amar
a quien él o ella quiere amar.
Vivimos en un mundo
donde el odio está en todos lados.
Donde los políticos dicen cosas
en las que no creen.
Un mundo en el que las personas
están más preocupadas por su aspecto
que por cómo tratan
o sienten el uno por el otro.
Necesitamos más amor.
Necesitamos más sinceridad.
Necesitamos lo que la comunidad
LGBTQU nos está mostrando.
El orgullo de ser lo que somos.
La honestidad de vivir
de la manera que queremos.
El coraje para luchar
contra la injusticia.
El amor contra viento y marea.
Quizás en este momento
se estén preguntando
cómo lidiar con este tema.
Y permítanme decirles que
no necesitamos lidiar con este tema.
De la misma manera
que no tenemos que lidiar
con lo que otras personas
hacen o piensan o dicen.
Es su derecho a hacer o pensar
o decir lo que quieran.
A lo único que
le tenemos que hacer frente
es a nuestros propios prejuicios.
Lo único de lo que nos tenemos que cuidar
es de no hacer que alguien más
sienta pena por ser lo que es.
Y esto es particularmente cierto
en nuestras aulas.
Para los que somos maestros.
Porque no solo
enseñamos nuestra disciplina,
sino también actitudes y valores.
También para los que son estudiantes.
Tratando a sus compañeros
con respeto y sin prejuicios.
Y si hay alguien en este salón
que cree que vive
de una manera contraria
a sus sentimientos,
que tiene que ocultar quién realmente es
a causa de lo que piensan los demás,
permítanme sugerirles
que no lo hagan más.
La vida es una sola y merecemos vivirla
a nuestra manera
y con nuestras propias verdades.
Entonces, seamos parte del debate,
participemos activamente en la defensa
de los derechos individuales
de las personas,
enseñémosles a las personas
con las que convivimos
a no hacer comentarios hirientes
sobre nadie más.
Y aún más importante que eso,
aprendamos a pedir disculpas
si involuntariamente decimos
algo hiriente sobre otra persona.
Espero que, como dijo
el pianista Seymour Bernstein,
con estas palabras haya podido inspirar
una respuesta emocional en todos Uds.
Muchas gracias.